[Music]
now brace yourself for some bachelor
bombshell straight from our favorite bad
girl contestant Corinne Oh jeah she sat
down for some girls off with ETL lines
lauren zima fall getting what else
pedicures at the Four Seasons Los
Angeles what surprised you when you
first got to a mint instead living there
there's a laxative in every bathroom
what that's bombshell number one and yes
you heard her right it was like a week
where we were all like I haven't pooped
in like seven days it's stress of it
being in a different environment I think
it's just to travel the stress Bob Jill
number two the rented house that looks
so luxurious
it's more soundstage than home sweet
home there's one bathroom in each room
that's small and my narrow is like a
caged mirror for like decoration I'm
like well this is stupid
how are you supposed to get ready we're
girls we are five to a bedroom and five
to one bath you're doing a lot of making
out I don't know what's Arthur Mints all
over the bachelor mansion you know what
there was
and I definitely use my fair share of
them yeah
something else we didn't see Corinne
softer side she and Nick had some deep
conversation which never made air you
know there's a lot of things that people
didn't see so they were so quick to
judge but you know can we see this
machine what would you advise people
were thinking about going on the show
picking up her skin such a big girl and
big boy panties on you're gonna need
them
you